[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants ont ce bidon
nounours tu es petit ami étaient trois
oursons deux neveux ont l'air bien
bruyant ce soir
pourvu qu'ils ne se fassent pas de mal
patron je descends le pauvre chéri
qu'ils sont cités parmi des territoires
grosse maman poule de nounours mon
échelle mais où est elle
je suis mort d'inquiétude le voleur au
bon endroit au bon vous êtes près les
odeurs on recommence le cancer
nous on change mais ne jouais pas trop
faim bonsoir les enfants que se
passe-t-il
il n'y a pas de bleus sur ces neuf
caisses quelqu'un on n'était pas malade
moi je me porte très bien vous nous ont
fait un concert de soldat et tes neveux
il joue très bien que la trompette et je
traduis cette famille on va jouer pour
toi non tiens mais ces chapeaux tuer
mais le capitaine des soldats ou oui je
suis le capital
mon chapeau
la et de la discipline reine en avant la
fin c'était trop bête qu'on atteint
quand je l'entends je suis content c'est
là que ton face à mu et nounours va nous
accompagner au monteur sur lui je lis
pas neige remontera sur les chevaux de
bois on irait jouer aux anneaux on
regardera le zoo tôt on rencontrera des
amis qui sommes nous aurons deux aussi
nous nocera chercher de gros mieux c'est
que nous nous sommes battus nous garde
après jean sera fatigué
se reposer jeunes après le dîner on
indiquait ce congé c'est très bien mais
ne veut chéri vous êtes fin musicien et
non vous chantez très bien quand même
vous avez bien venu ce soir
oui on a de la mousse au chocolat avec
la crèche
il ne vous en reste plus à petit tout
par hasard tu es fini les petits pois
frais ce dommage est bien qu est-ce que
vous avez bien dit du giallo méthane ou
cochet
rémi toto et fanfan vous êtes prêt à
vous capital attention
en avant marche produits soldats
n'oubliez pas d'enlever vos chapeaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonne nuit les petits soldats
ah voici notre capitaine l'ours en vous
en dhr pas trop en route capitaine paru
patron bleu nuit les enfants embrassé
très fort vos parents et allez vite vous
couchez fait de bonnes nuits
[Musique]